well it has been a very consequential 24
hours for uh donald trump for
the justice department for the january
6th committee we have so many pieces of
breaking news to talk about and i want
to start first and foremost with a
federal judge's opinion that donald
trump likely committed multiple felonies
in trying to overturn the results of the
2020 election now we're going to talk
about what this means and what it
doesn't mean and many of you rightly
writing to me correctly writing to me
and saying david wait a judge determines
whether trump is guilty doesn't a jury
do that
this is not a determination of
criminality for the purposes of
punishment donald trump has not been
charged the context here is evidence and
does there
appear to be
a legitimate reason
to turn over certain records on the
basis that it seems reasonable
that donald trump committed crimes and
thus the evidence is
legitimate to be looked at by
investigators and we're going to talk
about that and we have some very um
specific comments about this from legal
experts let's start with the new york
times article federal judge finds trump
most likely committed crimes over the
2020 election the judge wrote in a civil
case the illegality of the plan was
obvious
separately the january 6th panel voted
to recommend contempt of congress
charges for two former trump aides
this article is worth reading in its
entirety the important points here a
federal judge ruled yesterday that trump
and a lawyer who advised him on how to
overturn the 2020 election
most likely had committed felonies
including obstructing the work of
congress and conspiring to defraud the
united states the judge's comment on the
civil case of the lawyer john eastman
marked a significant breakthrough for
the house committee investigating the
riots the committee is weighing making a
criminal referral
to the justice department had used the
filing in the case to lay out the crimes
it believed trump might have committed
importantly trump has not been charged
with any crime the judge's ruling has no
immediate practical legal effect on him
but it ratifies the committee's argument
that trump's efforts to block congress
from certifying biden's win
could well rise to the level of a
criminal conspiracy
this is we we can't let this be
normalized
it is outrageous that this is what is
going on judge david carter wrote
quote the illegality of the plan was
obvious our nation was founded on the
peaceful transition of power epitomized
by george washington laying down his
sword to make way for democratic
elections ignoring this history
president trump vigorously campaigned
for the vice president to
single-handedly determine the result of
the 2020 election so what are our
questions here well the first question
is
does this
finally
give the attorney general merrick
garland
a way to move forward
with the criminal charges and the answer
is it probably does but he probably
won't
now what's really important to
understand here is
what does this mean this is not a judge
ruling
that a crime was committed
that's for a jury to do if charges are
brought but i asked former fbi special
agent who's now a lawyer asha rangapa
she teaches at yale law school i asked
her about this on twitter and she
explained very clearly quote the judge's
opinion
isn't itself evidence of a crime it's an
evaluation of some of the evidence
which is the grand jury's job
i'd say at most it suggests that a grand
jury would be able to independently find
probable cause to charge but the problem
is proving it beyond a reasonable doubt
to a jury
asha went on to add the judge may have
just been stating what was obvious from
the evidence but no doubt it's a major
flag
that this had better be an active
department of justice investigation
dereliction of duty if it is not so this
is the main point and we've been talking
about this for some time
i don't think anybody is arguing now let
me put it a different way
due process holds
that
one is innocent until proven guilty and
due process holds that we can't say
someone should be punished for a crime
until they've been found guilty of a
crime and right now donald trump has not
even been charged so we're
you know the right loves to say they're
all about law and order but they will
immediately suspend due process when
they want someone quote locked up think
hillary clinton we're not going to do
that we're going to stick to due process
but what is abundantly clear at this
point
is we have endless opinions including
now from a federal judge
that it's at least quite plausible
that felonies have been committed and so
what does that mean it doesn't mean you
throw someone in jail after before
getting a guilty verdict but it does
mean there should be an active
investigation and asha rangapa is
completely correct about that so this
ruling affects a very specific part of
the process of investigation it relates
to a civil case it's not time for jail
we're not saying lock anybody up it's
the right that loves to do that by
skipping due process but what we are
saying is if there's no investigation
going on right now
it raises some major major questions
that we need to have answered and
unfortunately
what we saw in manhattan
is very similar to this remember that
mark pomerantz and another prosecutor
investigating trump criminally in
manhattan resigned
and initially many on the right were
saying they resigned because they knew
that it was all bogus and there was
nothing to investigate no
we speculated and it's since been
confirmed
they resigned because they actually
thought wow trump did commit crimes
and it doesn't seem there's any interest
in actually charging him and so our work
is essentially being done for nothing we
found evidence of criminality nobody's
interested in charging the guy i'm out
of here that's what happened so we're
seeing the same story
federal judge
civil case manhattan investigators
everybody coming to the conclusion
felonies were probably committed here
will he be charged
i'm not i'm not particularly optimistic
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blink is for free and get 25 percent
off a subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below